Let's pray together for day 14.
Father, we are deeply thankful
that you have given to us the holiness without which no one
will see the Lord. You have gifted that holiness to us, not
just legal forgiveness of sins,
but also spiritually pouring into us the
new life, breathing into us again the breath of life
spiritually as you did for Adam physically at the beginning.
We thank you, Lord. In a moment of time, we have been gifted
holiness. We couldn't have earned it.
We couldn't have worked hard enough to deserve it, but you have given
us the gift of being one of your saints, one of your holy ones.
Lord, thank you. Help us to live that out.
You have declared that we are this, and now, Lord, help us
to live out that holiness, not to leave
holiness and being a saint to some
imaginary group of super Christians.
But Lord, make me a saint. Make me everything
that you've claimed that I am. Everything that you call me, now produce
it in me. Lord, I pray that you would help me
and my friend who is seeking the Lord together with me here.
Lord, would you help us to truly rise up and
become the people that you say we are?
We know that, Lord, that the holiness that you have given to us needs to be
followed. It has a will. It has a plan.
It has a direction. It has a goal for us.
And so, Lord, we yield ourselves. We yield ourselves to the goal of
holiness, to the goal of seeking after you.
Oh, Lord, make over my character. Make over my
heart until not only outwardly but inwardly I am
everything that Jesus died to make me.
We pray these things in His great and good name.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together for the rest of this time in your
own words.